to pay my respects to juicy
i've decided to show up today in subway
colors
unfortunately preach is still not here
today but we got some big news
yo
yeah
juicy is guilty
of all charges
of course of all charges bros of all all
charges how's how you feel about it
good good
good of course he's guilty of all
charges what the [ __ ] you mean you're
gonna [ __ ] jerk the guy
off
you're gonna you're gonna gaggle you're
gonna goggle his [ __ ] income right
then after that you're gonna hire him to
[ __ ]
uh do race play [ __ ]
[Music]
you're gonna hire him to do some raceway
[ __ ]
and then after that you're gonna say
maga
no
it was not maga it was [ __ ]
[Music]
oh man they really got this man this man
was out here getting hand jobs and then
he said hey man can you do a race job
afterwards that's wild bro
[Music]
all right after i suck out your semen
can you pour some bleach on me let's get
an extra white imagine having somebody
successfully jerk you off and you still
don't get a happy ending oh yeah yeah
i gotta jump on my way to [ __ ] subway
[ __ ] chicago minus
yo after i get that foot long i'm gonna
pretend i'm getting another foot long
and i want you to ambush me with some
bleach
i got ambushed by two foot long
[Music]
and to make this whole scam even better
don't have to make the whole scam even
better the [ __ ] who attacked him were
in nigeria
[Music]
the only thing we're missing are a few
indian telemarketers and this is a whole
ass
full-on scam
yeah that he [ __ ] called uber and it
was an indian dude
and then the [ __ ]
yeah i'd like to get mauled by two black
nigerians [ __ ] with manga hats
and a noose around my you know what if
this wasn't a hate crime this i'm pretty
sure all right big pause before i say
this would be a great premise for like a
porno you know what i mean like
yeah yeah like like you always see it
right you see a white girl running
through the hood and two [ __ ] come out
the window they like come here white
girl we're gonna fix your car and she's
like i don't have a car like well we're
gonna change your oil she walks in i
feel like it's like this it's like on
that left this was a porn plot turned
into a hurt he cried
off tomorrow man yes it's gonna be full
of [ __ ] gay [ __ ]
and black dudes yes getting juicy in
chicago at night
oh my days get the [ __ ] out of here
of course he's [ __ ] guilty today's
video is brought to you by sandberg what
is sandberg well it's a fragrant
subscription service it basically gives
you access to 600 brands of fragrances
you know sometimes you don't know which
one to choose and you want to see what's
out there you want to try out stuff
become these really cool cylinders that
are super easy to use you just pop it up
here boom
that's it soup
super easy to use okay and you can use
it for 30 days try it out and if you
like it then you can commit rather than
paying hundreds of dollars for a
fragrance that you may not even like
long term this gives you a chance to
actually rock it wear it see how you
feel with it you choose what you want
you choose if you want a 3 6 or 12 month
subscription and then boom at your door
you get your fragrance and they have
high-end brands like prada gucci versace
as well as a variety of high-end
fragrances that you can choose from and
right now you can use my promo coupon i
might preach two to get 30 off your
first month on scent bird that's 11 for
your first month to get your fragrance
why not treat yourself all right well
listen bro listen bro i'm not going to
keep you you just have fun on tour you
do your thing and uh we'll catch you
back i don't know i don't know what
sentence is going to give though
who knows
they're saying the time they may get and
get
will vary i think what's important is
that he was found guilty and that people
start to think twice
before they try to do [ __ ] like this
because in my opinion it's like this
right
people i think i think people are like
why would somebody fake a hate crime but
i think it's now time for everyone to
acknowledge that some folks find
tremendous amounts of power in framing
themselves as victims in every situation
you feel what i'm saying and this is no
different he saw it as a potential
career advancement to have a hate crime
committed against him and so he had to
fake one to advance it for himself think
about that psychology that means that
victim status is so powerful
that [ __ ] will try to lie to
cops in the fbi to to to advance their
career
yeah
bro bro i'm telling you this
i'm pretty sure that he's gonna get like
house arrest and some [ __ ] like that and
he's gonna wish for joe oh that's so bad
i was wishing for jail yeah more black
people running trains on me
stupid are you stupid
hi bro i'mma let you go
hi man
if you're going to pretend that white
dudes are going to commit a hate crime
against you wouldn't it make sense not
to hire the blackest black people
possible nigerians i'm gonna love my
niger people all right burn a boy's king
all right well now a bunch of nigerians
are rolling their eyes for what reason
are you looking at me funny see you
could have just hired stacy dash and
candace owens and this would have been
way more believable but you had to go
for nigerian scammers
i knew they were lying nigerians can't
handle the cold you didn't see these
[ __ ] hate crime white supremacists
just shivering being like
mega
in the footage come on
yeah and i think guys at the end of the
day you know um
at the end of the day as much we're all
gonna have a laugh about this we all
knew that this hate crime was fake
um
i think what it really does showcase is
that people will go to insane lengths to
frame themselves a certain type of way
and it says something really terrible i
think
about our society in a way because
we do value that we do inherently want
to believe people who say they were
victimized why because we we understand
that there's been very few remedies for
them for so long but in that process
there's people who are opportunistic
there are people who would take
advantage of folks's goodwill and try to
frame themselves in a position put other
people at risk for their own benefit so
we also have to do our due diligence and
just understand like hey man if the
evidence is not there it's not there and
you just can't believe somebody and if
that story sounds fishy investigate it
okay because i can assure you every
black person who heard this story went
[ __ ] i think that's the main takeaway
for me but i'm glad the jury got it
right i'm glad this person was charged
and i'm glad that folks are starting to
open their eyes to the reality like yo
this is a real thing people do lie and
they don't need to make sense
people will lie for the most frivolous
things and they'll [ __ ] up your life
right so just remember that and yeah as
far as juicy goes good man good and
anybody else who fakes some [ __ ] like
that who who makes up these false
allegations good they should also be
dealt with you get zero sympathy for me
if you're gonna tell a lie and put other
people at risk i hope you end up in jail
i hope you do
because too often people who do this and
put other people's that life right
because like if someone's found guilty
of your lie they go to jail for like 16
20 25 years sometimes life
sometimes life
but if you're found to have faked a
crime how long do you go to jail
a year two years probation house arrest
no they need to stop they need to
increase the penalties if you found that
you're lying not if they can't prove the
case because that's a different thing if
they can find evidence that you 100 lied
and fabricated the whole thing
throw the book at them you there's my
take you should face more time than
whoever you try to put in jail
you're not saying like if you try to put
someone in jail for murder and you
fabricated the whole thing you should
face that plus some
just to deter people from ever trying to
fabricate these kinds of things i think
that's the way going forward but that's
just my thoughts maybe i'm going too
crazy maybe it's too radical i want to
hear from you guys what do you guys
think